et maintenant la seule urieta
une jeune belge que vous entendez avec
un groupe
récent elle s'appelle muriel d'accueil
de plus en plus de succès je crois que
ça plaît bien de génie il est très très
bien moi maintenant je me méfie de ce
que je dis pas ce que vous avez lu les
journaux ah oui à chaque fois que je dis
qu'il est chanteuse et bien on me
reporte des ouïes des relations avec
alors chez ces tensions ça veut dire que
si vous dites trop de bien de muriel
d'axer son nom vous pensez que demain
dans les jaunes on dira celle qui a
séduit johnny par exemple eh oui oui
l'achat m
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
muriel date chez elle en belgique pour
une séance d'agriculture bio un peu
particulière
on va aller les voir j'ai des amis qui
viennent m'aider pour planter les
petites secondes dans les petits pots
alors voilà la chambre de mon fils
transformer en serre et on était en
train de faire rire on a fait toutes les
tomates et alors maintenant on est dans
les piments piment doux qui sont les
poivrons et les piments les pilons qu'on
met dans relever les sauces ou autre
chose je veux mettre ma petite prime et
là aussi c'est un travail en équipe
puis direction le bureau muriel est très
actif sur le net et je me demande à
martine bastide dégager toute une
aile et va travailler un petit peu vain
va pas certain
d'être et qui donc ça c'est mon site ya
mes coups de coeur où il ya toute une
série de personnes que j'apprécie
beaucoup et alors mes coups de gueule
vaccin h1n1 mosanto leur fonctionnement
de l'argent dette ça il faut le savoir
que les banques nous prêtent de l'argent
qu'elles n'ont pas militante oui mais
j'ai voulu absolument équilibrer ma vie
avec des choses saines parce que si
c'est pour rester toute la journée
devant des mauvaises nouvelles - sinon
je me jette sous un train ça ça sert à
rien et quand il s'agit de respirer
muriel rejoint son mari pour une
promenade dans le domaine familial
que tu va déranger les oiseaux à
[Musique]
viana le la
du tout content petit petit petit point
qui ça la grande bouffe l'un c'est la
grande bouffe
un shérif toujours attentionné
[Musique]
chroniquer buzzer
yes
et la nature c'est avant tout une
affaire de famille avec ses deux frères
mais en fait c'est de renouer
véritablement avec la nature est avant
tout et que le plaisir voilà oui
avec les ouï-dire renouer avec la nature
avec eux on a tout coupé mais qu'est ce
que ça fait des heures extension des
prestations quoi mais c'est bien le lien
je ris quand on trouve un frère l'autre
n'est jamais loin fait mais qui fait la
grosse voix il avait 14 ans 15 15 15 15
16 histoire c'est qu'elle est malade et
scott avec un nom
croit que répéter pour le
betis est la fille de muriel
le sang
[Rires]
déjà c'est beau c'est magnifique je suis
vraiment fière d'elle de son parcours en
fait je suis vraiment fier de ce qu'il
fait aujourd'hui c'est pour le monde qui
qui me succède et qui me succède aussi
parce que je les générations d'après et
si je peux en faire autant pour mes
enfants plus tard je serai fier de faire
comme lui d'un
retour dans la forêt pour l'une des
activités favorites de muriel donc
normalement les câlins gratuits en
général ça se fait en pleine rue et
comprend les gens dans nos bras
et on les connaît pas mais on va faire
ça avec la forêt
il est heureux les + 5 à la voilà
au final le quotidien de murielle szac
c'est avant tout la nature la famille et
surtout une bonne dose de rire
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
yalta bienvenue sur le plateau de mon
appareil muriel vous êtes né le 11
juillet 1962 à namur en belgique sous le
nom de muriel des clés de maredsous voit
la famille nommée wii vieille noblesse
vieille noblesse oui puis à l'abbaye de
maredsous a été fondé et financé par la
famille descours
vous avez un château plusieurs
fois pour toute la famille des sky et
pâques moi c'est vrai c'est vrai c'était
une époque extraordinaire
alors votre père était forestier
pépiniéristes oui et les gens du village
vous appelez la fille des sapins jolie
oui mais j'étais souvent parce que je
faisais partie de la noblesse et papa ne
met pas trop que je me mêle
aux paysans ferme pas aux paysans ou
aujourd'hui du village
et puis moi je fais c'est évidemment le
mur je me retrouvais dans le bal du
village déjà j'avais déjà squatté trop
ses idées voilà alors votre maire et
directrice de chorale et vos premiers
contacts avec la musique ce sont les
voix de la chorale de votre mère
derrière les colonnes d'une église
depuis votre berceau et c'était
magnifique parce qu'il y avait plusieurs
voyaient parfois des partenaires 200
personnes à plusieurs voix et ont par la
suite j'ai participé à des chorales et
il ya des fois je me taisais tellement
que c'était magnifique pour entendre
toutes ces voix est magnifique et
pourtant vous ne rêvez pas d'être
chanteuse vous êtes intéressé par nature
humaine même par l'âme humaine voulais
faire des études de criminologie et par
la suite vous ferez plusieurs formations
en psycho et quatre en théologie oui ça
m'intéresse toujours d'ailleurs alors
vous faites aussi du piano et un jour
avec le fils de votre professeur de
piano vous décidez de faire de la
musique ensemble est votre première
oeuvre ces tropiques oui oui un assez
incroyable et puis alors vous allez
vraiment de l'énergie parce que vous
décidez de vous lancer vous commence
évidemment par changer de nom parce que
oui c'est ce que marc est sous les 45
tours s'est un petit peu
alors vous cherchez des clés ça peut
devenir doc dit double date exacte mais
en plus ça va bien avec mon personnage
ans je suis souvent d'accord entre eux
va positif ouais alors toujours très pro
vous charger un des mecs de votre bande
qui bosse à la télé d'emprunter
discrètement une caméra un week-end pour
aller faire le clip au bord de la mer du
nord à ostende à la cfu tropiques filmé
au plat pays quoi plat pays en plus il
faisait froid donc il ya le garçon qui
sort du salut ces primes pneumonie ouais
ça a été l'enfer quoi raufast été
drôlement voit le succès est immédiat un
pur se repiquent 1 c'est incroyable mais
c'était progressif au départ ça a été
bon dans mon petit village puis ça a été
la belgique et quand j'étais signe en
belgique et que ça a tout de suite fait
pas une explosion on va dire ben j'ai
alors j'ai eu eddie barclay qui a
téléphoné chez mes parents fin tout le
monde s'y est mis finalement c'est avec
eux que claude carrère que j'ai signé
ouais en 1986 souvent des huit cent
mille exemplaires de tropiques vous
restez 54 semaines au top 50 c'est
absolument a dû sinon ouais je crois que
j'ai vécu cette époque vraiment
bien bien ce soir aucune prise de tête
de toute façon je l' ai vécu mais
vraiment fou et je voulais rien rater je
voulais vivre ça le dis une fois mais
prévoit la rater alors vous fait des
tournées au québec des concerts au japon
enfin c'est absolument incroyable en
fait j'avais la présidente michael
jackson moi là-bas basket avait au moins
une dizaine de gardes du corps puis il
fallait deux heures à l'avance dans une
petite pièce avant les concerts mais moi
je suffoquais donc j'ai été visité
l'hôtel où l'endroit en même temps de
concert tout à l'état tout au dessus il
y avait une espèce de comme des
attractions il y avait un énorme ours et
je monte et c'est un ours mécanique et
puis j'étais là puis je m'amusais comme
un bébé quoi petite fille et me donne et
je m'amuse je m'amuse puis tout d'un
coup je vois des gars du court mais
excité en disant non pas pour marquer
quelques points quelques temps on va
tous nous alors j'ai vu l'heure je suis
arrivé c'était wen est arrivé en trombe
en me disant oui haye j'arrive en retard
n'était pas content il ya un moment
inoubliable sur un plateau télé grosse
émission quand johnny hallyday boussouf
des pattes de serge gainsbourg qui
voulait absolument se faire la petite
quoi avec tout le respect que je dois
bien sûr pour serge gainsbourg niveau
musical j'ai rien mais au niveau humain
je me suis dit si mme tout changer parce
qu'elle révèle on le connaît s'il a le
moindre geste déplacé celui en mai une
bombe je suis comme ça ça on peut être
le pape n'importe quoi mais là un
minimum de respect je lui remets une
mais le truc c'est que la presse
paris-match général avait repris donc
moi quand je suis arrivé en direct moi
j'ai 24 24 ans et je vois une espèce de
ribambelle de photographes mais je dis
maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe mais
moi c'était comme ça je paie de
s'emballer comme ça en disant pourvu que
bon ça n'arrive pas et bon et puis
finalement ça s'est passé nickel et j'ai
appris par après que
johnny hallyday avait envoyé des gardes
du corps je sais par quoi pour calmer
serge parce que terrifié alors la
célébrité arrive assez rapidement donc à
ce moment là vous êtes très très très
connus quelles ont été les réactions de
votre entourage votre père comment il a
réagi merveilleux au départ on fait pour
une des scans maredsous est chanteuse
c'est
pas bien je t'aime mouton noir de la
famille ça c'est clair puis après quand
j'ai pu lui offrir le voyage au japon où
et c'est très très stricte et alors je
me dis ça y est je me prends une pelle
et y en avait un dans le fond qui est
elle avec de mer rouge en train
d'applaudir restait mon père mais pas du
tout je ne prenais pas de peine mais
c'est parce que pascal à la cuisse clerc
comme ça non seulement étaient contents
ah ben oui mes frères aussi j'ai fait
participer mes frères donc eric et puis
emmanuelle qui est venu que je devais
emmener à l'île de la réunion ils
savaient pas ce qu'ils devaient faire et
dit que c'est pas grave qui suit ce gala
qui fait des buttes ou le suis pas en
train de faire des bonds sur le sur la
scène les relations avec les médias ça
s'est bien passé à cette époque père
ouais vraiment il y en a juste un mais
il en faut toujours un ou je ne sais
même pas dire qui mais n'a pas compris
mon humour donc il a dix mois mais elle
se la pète parce que il m'avait posé à
qu'est ce que vous aimez comme artiste
je dis pas par moi je vois pas ouais non
pourquoi il a pris sa part eu deux
arrêts et alors le lendemain la presse
un réel dac cela peut être
de gagner de l'argent avec ça beaucoup
ouais bah oui parce que j'étais mon
propre producteur et j'avais écrit le
parole de tropiques bon d'accord c'est
pas du baudelaire en attendant ben voila
et
oui donc effectivement vendus à pâques
et un
plus tous ceux qui n'ont pas été
déclarés
oui vous avez un peu d'argent de côté
mais il ya là il n'y a plus rien il n ya
plus rien on a tous une claque et parce
qu'on avait à l'époque fait et réaliser
un studio d'enregistrement à domicile 1
24 pistes le gros bazar ça nous a bien
sachez l'amour bah oui c'est alec
mansion donc que vous rencontrez à ce
moment là oui musiciens beige ouais avec
qui vous allez vous marier faire trois
enfants puis divorcé et alors alec et
ses frères forme léopold nord et vous
qui cartonne avec ses amours oui ça 187
deux tubes dans la même famille oui alex
vivait un petit peu mal
lui ça faisait dix ans qu'il était un
artiste vraiment reconnu vraiment il a
un talent fou mais ils me rencontrent et
je venais de signer avec carrère avec
tropiques donc moi en quelques mois il
voit sa femme pouf qui fait le tour du
monde machin et avait une espèce de bon
et puis je dis mais à l'hectare
tellement talent c'est pas possible de
nous un petit peu de des cassettes j'ai
fouillé j'ai dit attends ce morceau là
on va leur mettre ensemble il faut
trouver des paroles évasif quand j'ai
accouché de mon antoine le premier il
est parti faire le texte et cette venue
c'est l'amour c'est l'amour énorme tube
hausse va effectivement le meilleur
moment tout cette époque c'est quoi
merial 3 mais tu sais ce qui s'est passé
un truc de fou
j'étais très mal dans ma peau je vais
déjà des kilos en trop et
et là j'avais en plus oublier mes
godasses de scène je t'aime mal je suis
mais qu'est ce que je vais faire on me
dit me laisse tomber vent basket ok
d'accord et je regarde comment les
autres les précédents artistes se
débrouille avec le public alors ok on
cerne il ya 5000 personnes devant 4 4
mille 4000 et je vois que les 5 6 qui
s'adresse au public ne s'adresse qu'aux
cinq milles devant le dit ok je vais
choper les 4000 et les 4000 et j'ai fait
sur scène le pas de michael jackson mais
je ne serais même pas trop le faire
impôts si j'avais comme ça c'est arrivé
comme ça je crois que j'ai reçues
et ça a été mais le délire total
car tel point on est en tournée que les
autres artistes on est allé rencontré
l'organisateur pour leur dire tu me mets
où tu veux n'est pas derrière muriel
c'était malheur j'ai reçu des sacs et
des sacs de courrier par le facteur
reconnaître ce désarmement est le pire
moment toute cette époque j'avais un
agent non qui me vendait entre
guillemets dans des discothèques en
france sans mon accord prenez les 50%
d'acomptes et va dire la veille mary
hell d'ac ne veut plus faire
la soirée dont kg le volet de 50% et et
vous faisait une réputation épouvantable
j'ai reçu des lettres d'insultés que
j'en ai chialé après tropiques vous
sortez un deuxième single qui s'appelle
là où ça qui marche pas mal oui ensuite
je craque qui n'est pas un gros succès
non ça collait plus trop quoi alors vous
dites l'erreur en fait que j'ai faite
c'est de ne pas avoir enregistré new
york new york que je chantais dans les
boîtes les gens y demandait ça en rappel
en fait monde est pas trompé qui
demandait new york dior j'ai travaillé
pendant trois quatre ans avec un big
band de jazz ça a été ma meilleure école
au niveau vocal et vu que je n'avais
tropiques à l'époque on me disais mais
qu'est ce que vous avez comme deuxième
morceau du bon berger autant essayer
avec new york new york ouais vous dit en
fait je pensais que le public tournerait
le dos au jazz et quand vous voyez
arriver patricia kaas avec mademoiselle
chante le blues vous dit [ __ ] je fais
une connerie car oui une belle grosse
connerie là je m'en veux vraiment ça
c'est clair en 1996 donc dix ans après
tropiques vous revenez avec un album
intitulé eau et du vaisseau que vous
avez enregistré avec les musiciens de
michael jackson à los angeles
et puis avec une chanson de kim wilde
que vous aviez rencontré à la réunion je
crois qu'a fait lors de la remise des
des disques d'or ouais donc qui m'a aidé
son équipe était là donc on a vraiment
sympathisé elle a écrit une chanson
faune album je trouve ça génial malgré
les musiciens michael jackson et malgré
l'ascension de kim wan ho et du vaisseau
décolle pas quoi mais il a été saboté il
a été saboté parce que le directeur
artistique
il a mis mon album la poubelle donc la
maison sans l'écouter et on marque à la
ferme m'a dit on est désolé si lui ne
fera rien sur toi oublie on est désolé
on te rends ton contrat garde on avance
mais pendant ce temps là tout se sait
dans les maisons de disques et pendant
trois mois j'ai jamais su la réelle
raison mais ça se sait donc l'album de
muriel d'acs a été refusée chez sony
donc c'est un souci on va même pas leur
os a fait le tour des saltimbanques oui
voilà alors nouvelle tentative un an
plus tard avec un peu plus d'amour sous
le nom de black and ac oui oui puis là
aussi c'était très motivé mais de
nouveau il ya eu entre un gars qui n'a
pas fait son boulot niveau distribution
h1 et puis là j'ai dit bon maintenant
j'arrête voilà la bêtise a été on ne
peut plus vous essayez de vous lancer
dans l'agro forestier l'écologie vous
avez militante écologiste le combat
contre le vaccin du col de l'utérus
aussi et la chaîne 1 voilà et puis aussi
contre la version officielle du 11
septembre de fukushima c'est bien de
quelque chose que je déteste le mensonge
et la manipulation des masses donc je
m'informe énormément par des livres par
des par internet merci internet parce
que là on va chercher l'information il
ya autant de conneries que de bonnes
choses il faut savoir trier et j'ai
rencontré david ray griffin par exemple
le 11 septembre
j'ouvre les yeux j'en ai marre qu'on me
fasse croire des choses je ne veux pas
être un mouton je vais pas suivre quand
on me dit d'aller à gauche je veux pas
spécialement la gauche parce que bon non
je refuse j'ai envie de passer par moi
même et la liberté de penser
ça je veux la garder comme en septembre
nous raconte des histoires bas dans la
version officielle est quand même des
trucs énormes enfin il ya beaucoup
d'incohérences et je sais que jean marie
bigard eu des problèmes à ce niveau là
mais tout ce qu'ils disent et c'est
cohérent et david ray griffin qui a
passé un temps fou à étudier mais il
n'ya pas que lui il ya les blés la
famille des victimes qui réclament un
nouvelle enquête et ça je la réclame
aussi cette nouvelle enquête alors
aujourd'hui nous rien est ce que vous
êtes nostalgique de l'époque de
tropiques non non non je suis content de
l'avoir vécu bien entendu mais j'ai
cette chance de pouvoir nourrir ma vie
de différentes choses et pour moi c'est
une richesse si c'était à refaire votre
vie qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil
mais je crois j'aurai donc voilà je
n'aurais pas fait là où ça je crois que
j'aurais fait de new york il y aura ces
[ __ ] travail c'est salir away et puis
après arrêter quoi
le jour vous allez mourir que je voulais
qu'on remarque sur votre tombe
je reviendrai
c'est très heureux
les pointures de ne rien rater de ligne
youtube abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus